[Musique]
ils ont réussi leur pari construire un
exemplaire de la vis aérienne mais cinq
siècles plus tôt de l'imagination génial
de léonard de vinci
[Rires]
un mois plus tôt à l'atelier de
métallerie du lycée jean lurçat
c'est la course contre la montre
[Musique]
pierre chauvin fait le va et vient entre
deux cours pour contrôler les pièces au
moment ils doivent une épaisseur de 15
mm ça fait 40 mm hockeyeur à 25 mètres
il va se promener sa des films et c'est
là que ça devient intéressant quoi voilà
et puis pour les élèves voire la
contrainte du délai qui qui pointe son
nez tout doucement là donc on sent on
sent qu'on est vraiment dans des
conditions d entreprise qu on va
terminer directement la fabrication en
fait du des principales lens ou des deux
des principales en fait tu y vas au
centre ils vont au centre directement
fait du d'armature et c'est ça qui va
contenir le tube carrés qui va permettre
à l'hélice en fait de tourner autour en
fait voilà on travaille dans l'urgence
mais bon on sera dans les temps
heureusement que j'ai des élèves en fait
qu'ils ont réalisé leur stage là dessus
on fait des aides de tpm des terminales
ces apps et qui aurait dû aller quatre
semaines en stage en entreprise
donc je les ai gardés exprès là on n'a
pas failli à 70 80 62 taux de définition
julien finalisent les soudures dumas de
la vis construire un prototype c'est une
première pour lui l'occasion d'apprendre
à travailler en équipe de l'activité
s'il y en a un qui part faire une pièce
ailleurs et bah il peut tout faussé du
couffo tout ce qu'on travaille ensemble
et comme une famille il faut pas parler
sein dans l'eau sinon il va faire
n'importe quoi et ça peut retarder
de cet atelier sortira la plus haute vis
du monde jamais réalisée d'après le
croquis de léonard de vinci
lavisse aérienne s'inscrit dans la série
de machines volantes que le génie
italien a dessiné entre 485 et 490 grand
observateur de la nature adeptes avant
l'heure du biomimétisme
parmi tous les rêves de léonard il y
avait celui de voler
tu veux commencer cinq siècles plus tard
les élèves en métallerie apprennent à
naviguer dans la structure de la vis
grâce à un programme de réalité
virtuelle à la violence
je rentre carrément dans le dans la vis
et je peux voir valeur légale et tout ça
sans forcément un temple en coupé ou
autrement on voit la couleur on voit la
différence des matériaux pour la
fabrication ça permet de concrétiser les
pièces qu'on fait ici voir à quoi ça
ressemble qu'est ce que tu vois ce
programme de réalité virtuelle c'est
pierre chauvin qu'il a conçu une
innovation dans l'art d'enseigner que
l'éducation nationale souhaite étendre à
l'ensemble des établissements français
est à deux autres roulement de chaque
côté je dois retenir commandes
c'est déjà pas vraiment du futur pour
tous les enseignants oui oui
avec ça on va pouvoir faire du jeu vidéo
c'est à dire qu'on va pouvoir
à aucun moment on a dit que l'école ça
devait embêtant mais que ce n'est pas là
pour être bientôt l'école ces faits
pourraient apprendre des choses que et
si on peut apprendre de manière ludique
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant pour tout le monde
plutôt que de forcer les gens à utiliser
encore des méthodes qu'on utilisait
avant parce qu'on n'avait pas les
technologies modernes
[Musique]
les plans de la vi ont été réalisés ici
à l'école polytech d'orléans par six
élèves ingénieurs
[Musique]
on partait vraiment juste un plan de
léonard de vinci
il y avait rien qui avait été fait avant
mais c'est ça aussi ce qui est bien
c'est que c'était un projet vierge ce
qui est vachement agréable c'est que
justement le fait que ce soit des
recettes c'est qu'on puisse concrétiser
certaines choses qui ont été faits par
un intrigant familiale semble donc de
tout ça c'est vrai que ça a fait un
projet assez atypique léonard de vinci
avait marqué dans le codex que
l'extrémité de la vie ce soit un câble
de faire de la grosseur d'une corde et
que du centre cercle il y ait une vie
brasse on avait besoin de deux cerveaux
pendant au moins une semaine pour faire
les papiers à l'avant effectivement
c'est dur à mettre en place sur un
logiciel 3d même à notre époque en 2019
donc voila mais ça se fait très bien on
a réussi avec la validation derrière par
nos professeurs qui nous ont cas tout au
long du des sommes allouées sur ce
projet bonjour le grand ordonnateur de
la vis c'est lui jean-pierre en cuisine
professeur de mathématiques
ça va deux bonjour tout va bien je pense
qu'il ya des soucis quand même et le
souci aujourd'hui ce sont les deux
moteurs censés élevé la vis et ses 850
kg c'est plus de deux fois la charge
initialement prévu on avait un souci
parce que les deux moteurs tiennent dans
une cage cette cage on a vu que
esthétiquement impose un problème et on
a dû plusieurs fois la redimensionner la
modifier est-ce que vous avez travaillé
là dessus on a allongé le diamètre de la
cage du coup
peu va rentrer à la fois les deux
moteurs et les éléments de transmission
de manière assez compact tout en
équilibrant les masses le concept c'est
quand même le concept précurseur de
l'hélicoptère s'était juste en fait le
début de l' idée il manquait un bon il
manque un le côté moteur mais aussi il
faut un moteur en feu dans l'autre sens
pour comme dans le cas des hélicoptères
donc c'était c'était une bonne idée
elle était juste peut-être pas abouti
de l'autre côté des alpes à florence non
loin de l'endroit où les leonardo leurs
alter ego de l'école d'ingénieurs ont
été chargé e de concevoir la voilure de
la machine
[Musique]
dévoile conçue en italie est fabriqué en
france
ici dans les faubourgs d'orléans
[Musique]
dans cet atelier installé au sous sol de
la maison familiale
loïse coupe etc ou les panneaux de la
voilure
[Musique]
donc c'est super voilà là on nage et
finissent à comment on fait du coup pour
la ronde 10 et surtout pour les bouts
jean-pierre assez le maître d'oeuvre de
la vis
une réalisation dont il a eu l'idée à
son arrivée à orléans et comment ça va
se mettre en tension se fait ici là ça
va pas rester droit je vais dessiner la
ronde d'accord peut-être qui est
l'élément déclencheur de ce fait plus
dans ma vie personnelle c'est que voilà
notre fils aux 10 à jour on a appris
qu'elle avait greffé et je l'avais écrit
sur un bout de serviette sur un coin de
table dans un café que je lui ferais un
spectacle en fait ce spectacle c'est pas
tout à fait ce que j'ai fait je me suis
plutôt orienté vers une exposition une
exposition sur le thème de renaissance
mais renaissance avec un s et parmi les
renaissance que va fêter la région
centre val de loire qui a fêté la france
qui va fêter l'italie il ya notre petite
renaissance familiale qui tient du fait
que la grève de lui s'est très bien
passé ça nous a changé la vie ça lui a
changé la vie
et voilà donc je sais un petit tout est
mêlé que j'ai envie de dire tout est
mêlé loïse a pu mener à bien son bac pro
de couture elle a entrepris de tailler
les voiles de la vis dans un coton
d'egypte très dense de couleur écru
identique à celui utilisé au xvème
siècle
challenge c'est que je fais de la coupe
industriel mais en version artisanale
voilà c'est ça je mélange de technique
et je mélange du coup mes 2 mai deux
apprentissages
il
c'est à mauricie qui incombe la
responsabilité ben arfa tiennent que ce
soit bien fait que ce soit comme ils
veulent et c'est à dire soit bien
entendu tout ça l'intérêt de mettre des
scratchs c'est qu'ils puissent eux
tendre et ajuster un machine parce que
concrètement moi je n'ai pas vu la
veille film voilà je fais avec les
informations qu'on ne nous sommes j - 4
avant la grande exposition de la vis à
orléans à la cité des métiers les
ébénistes fabrique les ultimes habillage
de la vis des poignets du cabestan
réalisé avec du chêne façon renaissance
c'est le style qui fait la charnière
vraiment entre le moyen âge et l'époque
monarchique que tout le monde connaît
avec louis 15000 16 les beaux meubles
on s'est vraiment l'époque charnière où
où on sort du coffre
brut on arrive à un meuble et les
ébénistes au xvème siècle faisait appel
à un ingrédient bien spéciale les deux
groupes s'étaient l'huile de coude
c'était un tour comme ça
qui est régulé qui tourne toujours à la
même vitesse qui tient parfaitement le
morceau de bois ça n'existait pas
c'était tout à la main
c'était voilà ce qu'il faudrait ça c'est
le fraiser quand on met un coup de frein
est là pour préserver qu'on puisse
mettre une vis qui soit adaptée
jean-louis chemin enseigne l'ébénisterie
depuis 20 ans au centre de formation des
apprentis
ici le projet d'habillage de la vi a
suscité tout de suite l' enthousiasme
qui est intéressant sur le fond et sur
la forme c'est à dire que nous on était
centre de formation et que bien
évidemment tout le monde était impliqué
y compris nos apprentis nos propres
apprentis du centre de formation donc
ils se sont appliqués sur ce projet on a
fait quelques recherches aussi puisqu'en
fait on rebondit aussi sur l'histoire du
style c'est à dire que toute cette
période renaissance
on est reparti sur un cabestan de
bateaux pour essayer de 2,2 de renouer
aussi avec le temps passer tous les
éléments
essentiel de cette période direction
maintenant la collégiale saint-pierre le
pus ailier d'orléans où jean louis et
benoît vont arriver une partie de la
visage sur la vis
as tu es content c'est bien les mecs
sont super
[Musique]
il reste encore beaucoup à faire avant
l'inauguration
ça va aller on est on est dans les
délais il nous restera plus que la
partie cabestan la partie supérieure qui
n'est pas monté sur la structure c'est
en cours nous allons certainement
l'installer demande
j - avant l'ouverture de l'exposition
laury's procèdent aux derniers
ajustements sur les voiles comme pour un
défilé de mode
je suis un peu à la bourre forcément il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses
à retravailler c'est en fait c'est du
caire rapporte lui de cerclage de la vie
ce qui a dû être ressouder dans
l'urgence donc bien soudé des pièces des
pc cdfa remous
sinon quand on assemble après ya
toujours des 6es cas et c'est la mise au
point
[Musique]
place à la phase d'essai la vie s'élève
les deux moteurs vont ils supporter la
charge de 850 kg qui marche très très
bien
elle tourne elle monte elle descend
c'est ce qu'on voulait donner une âme en
fait à nîmes et donner une âme ce que
des renards voulait quand il nous a dit
mes machines
il leur manque quelque chose c'est l'âme
des oiseaux l'âme pour voler une
mécanique de la vie qui aura demandé
près d'un an de conception et de
fabrication
[Musique]
la plus haute vis aérienne au monde
porte une aventure technologique et
humaine qui aurait séduit léonard de
vinci lui qui place l'homme au coeur de
ses réflexions
[Musique]